We are out here
for about 3 hours a week
we've got about 25 kids
who are freshmen through seniors
every kind of different concentration
from anthropology and archeologists
some from computer science and government
I have never taken any archeology courses before
so this is my first
excavation
What do you think? I like it.
it's very very cool
I've been excavating over by Massachusetts Hall
for most of the time
and we've been coming up with a lot of cool stuff
so I really, it's been really cool for my first time
to be able to find so much stuff too.
Like what? A lot of pottery and ceramics
and a lot of pipe stems
and actually a lot of bones too, like a lot of
we're thinking they're probably cow bones
maybe from like the garbage from a kitchen or somethinglike that
so that's been really interesting
finding that kind of stuff
I did an excavation in Jordan and one in Germany
but they were very different sites from this
so it's interesting to do historical archaeology
for the first time
because everything else I've done has been
pretty historical.
I think it would be really neat to find
remnants of the Indian college
or just some material that you can identify
as ,like, used by the students
you know that would be really exciting.